hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bend the exorcist I'm
assuming that I'm Ben and I see
something popping out from behind the
couch there if you look right oh why
hello do I need to exercise you ooh
difficult story lover watch your back
may God help you I'm just gonna do watch
your back because you guys need to watch
your back it's already in your house
it's already standing right behind you
but don't turn around cuz that'll really
piss it off I know hello this is Ben the
Exorcist the call was from with the
Witherspoon family I could sense the
terror that they had been through in the
moment I heard Gerry's voice is Jerry my
old pal from the war days and the
Exorcist please help us then he told me
the terrifying story could happen in
their new house oh it all started on
Halloween when his daughter with their
friends decided to perform a spiritual
ritual of course why not they've
awakened dark spirits since that day
life of the Witherspoon family became a
nightmare every time they already
burgers the circumstances Oh
all healthy organic gluten free food
ends up in the trash bin expensive
organic food son became sick all the
time the doctors couldn't care daughter
Kinsley because of some strange noises
that bother her every night not this
terrible song again I'll be deaf soon ok
well sleep somewhere else the strange
with the stinky smoke that comes from
nowhere firefighters that come to the
house accuse family of doing stupid
jokes made them pay an expensive bill
Wow life is just hell everyone's gonna
die or something why nobody believed I
was their only hope
ah you need to leave the house
immediately I'm on my way I can't
believe they didn't think of this before
leaving the oh hi let's find out this
girl's activity oh boy Ben's on the case
here Ben's gonna find out
ready ghosts over here huh I got my
cross here are no Mach 2 thing so strong
oh I think there are more hotter spots
how many more could there possibly be
press 2 to use it
select aspergillum oh yeah I don't know
what that did but I did some about it
can I go in there oh just like that oh
yeah alright so what is this my this is
my detector Oh
this spot is particularly on to my
cottage in July defendants Prairie oh
all right
sarsaparilla avocados something like
that I think I did good I think I did
good there so I got a detect me some
haunted locales hello is the backyard
haunted I can't see jack doodlee I don't
know if my things spinning about here oh
I got hit with a ray it gives back again
can I get this this sarsaparilla what do
you see on the inkblot test okay
it's blue sheet split oh she okay maybe
not
hello Merida help Oh oh wow wow it's an
actual working mirror no way in hell is
this even possible
there's been games I'm playing pray
right now and even they don't have
working mirrors Oh these days are blank
ah okay I guess it always a clever ruse
alrighty then this is obviously not
haunted here ah I didn't get this spot
hang on hang on hang on hang on whoa
nope whoa here we go the promoter took
the princeps media authorized this
I don't know what those words mean but I
hope it's doing the demons away I'm just
gonna keep splits flashing down until I
get to where I need to go what happens
if I splits pacifier
is this gonna do anything oh yeah I
can't put it out I've got an unlimited
supply of holy water apparently which is
good I think
hello I think that did it oh hi okay
well that's a good poster to have this
is one of the kids rooms or something
hello there's this one haunted a little
bit of spinning action but not a lot
maybe in the clue hi barb gentlemen the
flower curse ah lovely
okay then somewhere nearby oh that's it
this is it oh man indeed Oh what the
hell
it should be still two o'clock ah easy
job look around I don't know what that
means by easy job hello hello I've got
the sploosh in water you don't want none
of this alright no I can't see anything
ooh ominous music if someone gonna steal
my burgers or is someone actually gonna
spook me here hmm oh hi oh hi hello I'll
go up in the attic in just a bit
I need to investigate whatever this
means you get a spook ooh somebody out
there okay F hi Jerry Jerry hey come on
now could you just make your first enemy
this seems like a lot less like a go
some more lights
Cuchillo oh he's gone
apparently that worked okay
well the door wasn't even open so I
don't know how that worked Oh God hello
hi no no no akamalik almost gotcha oh
yeah yeah you get nothing on me what do
you mean exorcism doesn't work she's got
exorcised he got exercise - no huddle of
goop what holy water I thought I had
enough holy water you are not prepared
info about ghosts and perfume bottle
okay all right I'm gonna guess that i'ma
go wit is it's dark up here it's a whole
lot of dork the darkness it's all around
me
hi then okay okay well then that Mouse
met its bitter end then I did not
facilitate that in any way hello hi ah
yes good so how in the heck do I get to
what I needed
oh I can turn lights back on oh I didn't
know that was a thing
oh so that's gonna help me immensely
ah it's bright where's the dead rat cuz
that rat is dead for sure oh I guess
someone relax yeah I thought you knew
Jerry
you knew him on a first-name basis mr.
Witherspoon I'm pretty sure you're
familiar with Jerry - so just slings to
the ghost if I could clever for more I
would be able to find one this ritual
doesn't belong to the host ones but in
this case
since I have no choice okay yeah that's
a good fine the choke oh okay oh oh just
you're been here I'm gonna forsake all
of my training well I mean really just
beliefs in order to dispel this war and
ghosts this demon infesting this house
alright next issues play the computer
there all right what do we have here oh
my god oh the 200k anyway sorry about
that looks like the Sun here had some
other interests whoa why are you game
over what game over what did i do what
did I do wrong
what'd I do wrong what did you do to me
what did I do to me what did we all do
to each other what happened to us what
happened to us guys
stop don't be like that I don't know
someone will like buggers someone really
left hi what are you doing in there yeah
that's right here you're not welcome
here - doesn't belong to the whole east
ones but in this case it seems I have no
choice
yeah sure hello honey happy birthday to
you I wish you a wonderful life and that
you dreams come true me and your father
heard about you sickness it really must
be hard on you normally antibiotics
would work but because of your allergy
you can't take them from other hand
because of this you have become a
chemist right and that makes us really
proud anyway I hope your research goes
well and again I wish you success in
your 34 birthday your mum and dad how
long have they been dealing with this
curse
so you need to find the chalk to draw a
Pentagon tonight I keep this issue
oh I don't think she don't Stefan enough
called me here
what who is she you mean mom and dad who
are you talking about I was talking
about the son who's got all his jacking
books under his pillow my [ __ ] high
[ __ ] high no anything but that
oh no high poppers is that chica that
looks like chica alright then anything
oh the 200-year orgasm again what's this
this does not help me but maybe this
would no this is gross what's alleged
antibiotics this goes right way I
probably should go to the basement to
restore energy okay or maybe I could
just get out of this house and we could
burn it to the ground because that's
also an option we could do that we can
definitely do that anybody could do that
and I think it's we that we should do
that so how am I supposed to get down to
the basement all by my lonesome I'll
have a goddamn flashlight and I don't
even remember seeing the basement in the
first place how do I get to the basement
is there like a cellar door in the
backyard oh oh good I'll just go down
here then oh it's dark oh it's dark
oh it's dark Oh dark is what it is I
can't see [ __ ]
oh I see something here hello and almost
there
f I don't know hey I lost it oh there it
is
I don't know what that's doing I don't
know what that's doing did I do it I
don't think I did it
nope who's up there huh I need a
flashlight oh hi who's up there
something weirds going on and I don't
know what it is
oh hi I know what that sound was is that
lady crawlin hi sorry
oh oh what the [ __ ] is that okay bye
where are you going
yeah she's sumed right up those stairs
what is that yeah what is coming from
here no know what you're talking about
oh hi hello you okay
where's she though up and Guber gabbed
I'm gonna give this another try this is
getting a little a little bit janky here
but we're getting there I don't know
what I did am I at the power off stage
yet oh I'm up here now yeah gotta be
[ __ ] my donker good huh I got a
perfume bottle then I need to fill with
water for some reason christi filii I
use Dom ministry at India to pass Beauty
to suck okay holy water all right I need
more items connected to the ghost I
don't know where to find those but
to find him as best I could
oh it's also an ultraviolet flashlight
which is a weird thing to have in a
normal family household can I just make
it with that paint then all right I
think I'm onto something here
I think I'm onto something so now that I
got this flashlight once the power goes
out I'll be able to go down into the
basement not die horrible painful death
alrighty then off we go Skee deadly
wedley me hi lazy VT Cox [ __ ] are they
are they Cox fun is that what it is
ah no so I just don't oh boy oh thanks
ok alright
probably should I'll just see about that
and now that I got a flashlight it'll go
much easier for me okay here we go
skedaddle II do who's down here oh that
was a whole nother room over here that I
never saw because I couldn't see it
because it was dark no ah nail kills
nail kills like these nails like just
nail vanity or something no no you're
talking about
oh hello ah Kurt uncle's I think that
did something it looks like it did
something why are you trying to sell me
[ __ ] boost misfire lady guy dude can I
try to you know like exorcise you or
something hello hi okay goodbye then
I guess goodbye maybe I will get some
clues from the radio yeah okay yeah
let's go with that one that's a good
idea
definitely gonna get some clues from
that radio oh but the power works I
think which is awfully good and nail
also still kills but okay gone upstairs
now skedaddle edy skedaddle II do I'm
gonna keep that open just in case I need
to run this place where did you deduce
that from this from this action oh did
someone fall down the stairs so what
happened is it all the rakes and the GUP
lying around so just a small fire yes
I'm gonna go with yes oh hi oh okay is
this the fire department smell that
everyone was talking about is that a
cloud of death please tell me that's not
a cloud of death oh no no I can do about
that cloud that sure is a stank cloud
all right if I ever seen one what am I
supposed to do about the stain cloud
that's moving through this house well I
guess absolutely nothing then I'll just
let it carry on its life hiyee time you
doing some there is something wrong okay
so now we got that oh well anyway now
that we got that I thought the Crawley
lady was gonna come out after me again
but there's a safe there and I don't
know code I have any idea how to get a
code do I have an inventory of some sort
kappapa radio open plus there's a good
I hope the patches will work maybe I
should use the wrong
that one's like mommy did you overdose
from nicotine last smoke earring I don't
know what that means I don't understand
you
okay good alright then wait I need this
don't do empty I could use a drink right
about now that's for damn sure
man The Exorcist needs a goddamn drink
sorry sorry sorry
oh hello why did you reject me
hi I don't know oh hi hello hi okay fine
and also hello
try to exercise you I'm gonna get you
next time
but not today so is that the ghost of
someone that likes birds to death around
here or something
Oh what is that there was no he was here
before oh so that's what that was all
about so is there gonna be a demon in
here no no that one no no all right let
me try to go to another room
ah that's that's not good that's uh
despair a human boy a Buddhist oh boy oh
boy oh boy out there in the parody she's
venom croaking ah dad okay where'd you
go I don't want to go around that corner
because I've got a bad feeling about it
got a feeling I mountains just fall over
and die
hello where did you go oh I see oh yeah
yeah I know you don't know you don't
stop you did you did
why did you did oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh sure
[ __ ] you oh god damn it okay
that's Bob and all the patients I got
for that game anyway that is Ben The
Exorcist I may try to beat this again in
the future I was hoping to who's gonna
have a bit more humor to it because the
opening was so probably now that I
realized it unintentionally hilarious
and I thought it was gonna be a lot
funnier but maybe it will be in the
future I don't know if you guys want to
see me at the end of this let me know
down the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching it and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]